hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a really fun puzzle
the challenge is to make each number
from zero to ten
using three threes
in other words
make each equation true with equality
using
mathematical operations
there are many ways to do this and
here's a crazy hard bonus question find
two answers for three three three equals
ten using only the following symbols
plus exclamation point and parentheses
i thank yale from hong kong for
suggesting this problem and i give
credit to karl ho's channel his video in
chinese made this problem go viral in
hong kong
the puzzle went viral because of 333
equals 10 which is the hardest one in
this list
the crazy hard bonus might introduce a
new concept to you and i hope you will
enjoy learning it
there are other ways to solve 3 3 3
equals 10 and i'm going to present some
of those as well
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so many of these equations have multiple
answers and due to time constraints i'm
only going to present some of the
answers
if you find another method let everyone
know in the comments i won't be able to
respond to emails as i'm getting too
many nowadays
so let's get started
three plus three plus three is equal to
nine
we could also do three to the power of
three divided by three is equal to nine
next we can do three plus three minus
three to get to three
or we could also do three times three
over three
continuing
three plus three is equal to six we
divide that by three and we get two
another way is three minus three over
three
that also gets to two
to get to six we could do three times
three minus three
or we could do three factorial minus
three plus three
one creative way that you can get to six
is you'll do three
left shifted by three over three
this equals three times two to the power
1 which is equal to 6.
this less than less than is read as the
arithmetic left shift operator and
you're shifting by one binary bit this
is something computer scientists will be
familiar with and i got the idea from
the website cut the not
continuing on
we can get four
by three plus three over three
we could also do 3 factorial minus 3
factorial over 3.
to get to 1 one way we could do this is
3 factorial minus 3
and then we divide that by
we could also do three to the power of
three minus three
or we could do the square root of three
times the square root of three and then
we divide that by three that also gets
to one
to get to zero we'll do three factorial
minus three minus three
to get to five we'll do three factorial
minus three over three
we could also do three factorial over
three plus three to get to five
to get to seven one way is three
factorial plus three over three
we could also do three factorial plus
the quantity three minus three factorial
and because zero factorial is equal to
one this equals seven
we could also do three divided by point
three
subtract three and that also gets to
seven
to get to eight we have three factorial
plus three factorial over three
so now that brings us to the final
equation which is perhaps the most
interesting challenge
one way to solve this problem is you
take the arc tangent of the square root
of 3 and then you divide by the quantity
3 plus 3 to get to 10.
i saw this in a video comment on karl
ho's channel
the logic is that the arc tangent of the
square root of 3 is equal to 60 degrees
now technically you then divide by 6 to
get to 10 degrees but that'll be good
enough for this puzzle
another way that you can solve this is
you take
the square root of 3 plus the square
root of 3
you take that quantity multiplied by 3
that'll get you to a number that's
slightly larger than 10 so you then take
the floor function or round down to get
to 10.
i saw this on the website cut the not
three threes
now yale suggested three possible
solutions to this as well
here's one creative way
you take the square root of three times
three which will be three you then
divide it by three percent
three divided by three percent is a
hundred you then take the square root of
a hundred to get to ten
another solution is you take the log
with the base the square root of the
square root of 3
you take that of 3 and then you add 3
factorial
now the logarithm will evaluate to be 4
so then when you add 3 factorial you get
to 10.
another way is that you take three times
three that'll be nine
and then you add the following you take
the derivative of three which is zero
and then zero factorial is equal to one
so we have nine plus one and that equals
10.
amazing
so now
how do we solve this bonus question
two answers to get us to 10 using only
the symbols plus exclamation point and
parentheses
in order to solve this i'm going to
review some ways that you can use the
exclamation point
the most common way is n factorial or n
exclamation point
this is the number of permutations of n
that is the number of ways to arrange
the ordered list going from 1 to n
n factorial is the product of the
numbers from 1 to n and 3 factorial is
equal to 1 times 2 times 3 which equals
6. we've been using that in many of
these equations
but there's another way that you can use
the exclamation point
exclamation point n
is read as n
sub factorial
this is the number of derangements of n
these are permutations where no element
appears in its natural order
so let's calculate some of these
one sub factorial is equal to zero
this is because the list one has no
derangements the only way you can order
one is to have one
two sub factorial is equal to one
this is because the list one comma two
has the derangement two comma one
two is in the wrong spot and one is in
the wrong spot but there's no other way
that you could arrange the elements like
this
now for a list of three elements three
sub factorial is actually equal to two
why is that
well how can we put the list one two
three so that no element is in its
natural order there are two different
ways
we could have the list two three and one
or we could have three one and two
notice that in each of these the numbers
1 2 and 3 are all out of order
so it'll be very useful to us that 3 sub
factorial is equal to 2.
now just for general knowledge there are
formulas for subfactorial
and subfactorial is equal to the
following formula it's n factorial times
its alternating sum
you can also calculate it as the
following n sub factorial is equal to
the floor function
of n factorial divided by e plus one
half
this will be true for n greater than or
equal to one
so
how does three sub factorial equal to
two help us solve this problem
well one way we can get to ten is three
factorial plus three sub factorial plus
three sub factorial we have six plus two
plus two and that gets to ten
another way to solve this is three sub
factorial
multiplied by the quantity three plus
three sub factorial
we have two multiplied by three plus two
so we have two multiplied by five and
that also equals ten
so this is how you solve the bonus
question of getting to 10 using only the
symbols plus exclamation point in
parentheses
did you figure out these problems
and what methods did you come up with
please share in the comments
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free inspire and build confidence for
people around the world and they already
have over a hundred million views
let's share the beauty of mathematics
with your help we can math the world a
better place please subscribe for free
to get the newest videos watch and share
all of mind your decisions videos email
me a puzzle or math topic
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support